one of the first year memes we are here
in austin texas with all these programs
checking out movie screenings visiting
channels and having guest speakers come
to talk to us visually
you cannot fight my launch I also is
first you're mean to integrate doctors
offices I'm so people to love is my
religion
nico named jordan evening first-year me
from Nebraska lived in austin last year
so trace me back to conjointly once in
the south by kutless and I'm Elizabeth
I'm original Brooklyn and I am good mood
to talk about Lawrence and now I'm an
incident development for TVs no I'm
interested in music I'm television
production somewhat you spin your
favorite part of soft by so far so the
whole a little bit and I said that the
commencing here please first time I'd
like any traditional film
entertainment visible and the name
services for working in the dimion
solarion four people like there's so
many things we here
you know I am exhausted possess the
creating our generation was part of the
island and hiking come in here like
walking every day running from the
dishes week and explaining to you know
drink a beer the bodies and some friends
just move on and so happy that we
progress Ava its evolution to be here
again offering four times amazing often
in texas jerilyn cool i love it the
withering for green do you feel like it
was a more relaxed more approachable I
mean we leave New York in October which
I had to be on the entire time yes for
sure 30 more I much more work you but
still very very much orbit but a full
miles in see what the difference I don't
father's will be confined here
unique even like because those of us
call is so packed and like these service
industry people are trying to like get
you in and like get you served and
they're so like lazar like y'all we're
so sorry look just thanks for being so
patient so like it's like everyone's tie
or we're gonna smile on my face even if
you have to wait the line makes me
curious lots of waiting on line but it
really didn't at all deter for me
because once we got you're so excited
waiting on line and then once you get in
for link to a premiere for example I
couldn't sit still so it just seems like
every time so and then after the
commuters when the actors come out and
do the QA and you just sort of like see
the brilliance and it just for you and
Isis them and it's like okay you know
these guys are actual people and you
know maybe people we can be working with
in the near future so it's just
extremely exciting like I'm excited
amazing opportunity that's the program
office I think I really enjoyed just
running around the city that I truly
grew to love last year with new friends
that haven't been here before and just
like showing them around
giving the taste of six tree Red River
Street all the concert venues food
trucks at midnight memories in bed
there's all that great stuff that I've
added I've got to experience before hand
and just sharing it with people who
haven't haven't been here before I guess
we went to you a panel for a television
show that I got to work on to the party
food it was awesome I it like made me
don't smell out like have all my like me
family like watching something that like
I took so much work into in like a
completely different state and then I
got to you know what is that expensive
true success Rogen who didn't mean it
wasn't always upset he was like when
background working on other projects and
giving him feedback like long distance
so I'm super nervous what I was the
first person in line top and I got to
like think Jim poplin who is the show
mother like for giving me this awesome
experience of working Season 1's
creature and I asked us real good
question that like I wasn't thinking
about what I was working on the house
but because I plaster shows and kids
from email it instead of like talking
about equality and I you know we're 60p
things a little bit more
yeah thing am I wash silica gel Harry I
creature super cute coming up for sure
um no actually you require detail I went
to go until my obsession with Volvo to
turn from my dagger football oh I'm Jeff
and and fred armisen was interviewing
him like SNL zoo and I was like umm I
have to ask questions but i'm way too
nervous and I was like okay what would
later like I haven't had a like Whalers
Layla's like cool unlike and I did and
you know what I'm so proud of myself for
doing it like hers I know I would have
prevented it if I didn't go for it so
would you ask you so because there's
like 50 departs also wrote for SNL like
that was Chris Farley was on SNL yeah
and I I love writing like that's what I
want to get into and so I said to comedy
is such a fickle business how do you
manage in the span of your careers to
just a funny and relevant and I'm going
to be honest I don't remember their
answer because I feel like I've live so
nervous I like wood uncontrollably
thinking I was like oh I'll see any cool
okay so no I guess I was like what would
Leila do the home but it was I'm so glad
I did it seriously I thought it was cool
about that was he always talked about
how
he is early cop thinking about different
ideas even though he's like successful
any like pitch this like I'm in a
wetland he's done like it was pretty bad
myself is just the idea he's been
working on in his spare time and he just
like pitched it to everybody like any
tests will be assuring everyone he was
like I can make it work I can meet to
work I can make right oh it's just like
a different show than he had in mind
reminded us of like when we pitched our
script by using is like not even close
to this is my lil homie visit me so yeah
little backstory to that so our program
director had to keep a class called
Krypton story so we get a little bit of
an idea for that yeah withdraw circle
all right right and so we all come up
with ideas and then we practice pitching
and that sort of thing
valuable time to like your stories with
people that are really sick Pokemon that
you as my hand yet being in service as
you are in life dancers in stone okay I
can make that work I think you can learn
from that I basically always the Deaf
feeling of like
people already had chosen
for the BBQ
tell me what it was like to be able to
be walking down the street and see
actors or producers or I'll be waiting
I'm waiting three hours for x we always
a step ahead and you know help what for
that is to be 30 work the first role I
mean in the OC it's true cat and you
know it will force it and you know I
shall fight come on it isn't I'm gonna
cave you see people you know the actor
that I get all them on the show tonight
so you slide into her to see how other
we help others watch like and saw and
are you announcing for now GJ Omega
vision I am interpreter yep so there
will exit the work site is in
see the audience and give your people
Oh
kamijo i think that like the Pacific see
the creators of the castle
so I think you know Santa Cruz I am
quite the James subversion sand and
obviously some bald enemy is that has
ever walked off and he was doing a
preferred of these guys but he was doing
a special method B and I was juggling
the trigger to express the ball Tony but
there was so many things happening at
the same time empathy in film is it
really the most thing that I'm
interested in so I skipped it and then I
we were walking down the street and like
I was looking used to and I was like
spread and it's justin ball Tony was
just like standing on a corner and so I
made them take a photograph of me and he
was so kind and so generous and after we
took it's an amazing thank you amazing
picture and I'm you know afterwards he
was like thank you so much Michael to my
eyes making magic hug and I didn't
squeal until a strike on site so i think
it's pretty successful bunch of like
their to work yes yeah i just felt
really I i spelled alia starr sucks if I
have been working intention of thumb for
about three years so I don't really
answer that could it happen on occasion
in this effing definitely happened with
us
um and only person I ran into on the
street was Mick Portman yeah oh yeah i
did is on my like the first day but they
say anything goes like yesterday I
should have pressed I wanted to pester
am i doing like Reno 911 on how he
didn't take mine but uh now the panels
are really cool i thought the most
inspirational one was i was messin with
ya yeah right seeing her up there
talking and it's like caring about her
dad for me heavy today about like how
how much she works on the show and like
how involved she is and she's an
executive producer of it he's like she's
so awesome like I can't cruise
she's really awesome she worked super
hard and like operation yeah and just
again like it sort of like making them
appear human like she said the pair of
sundry youngest son is on the team at
George ham so like you know especially
I'm not look like oh my god for election
so like just to sort of be able to be
like okay can I be super successful and
then also have a real person life you
know and to see that you know someone as
successful as her is able to juggle it
and worked as hard
and a light and extremely nutritious and
what a little bit of subway out that so
we have opportunities to the producers
guild of america conference a little bit
early earlier and immunity miss a
talking about us examine 50 panels
whether they're in DC or New York or
here now in Austin that we've gotten
this amazing opportunity is like for me
at least the panel is where I just
learned the most because i'm not being
observational and not like watching
people work and try to figure out what
they're doing they're just directly
saying this is how that came to be and
this is me
tell me a little bit about the sessions
of the colonel mountain specific
sessions that you guys had it's Saturday
and Sunday yeah everyone able to find
something very helpful for his
information we don't believe
that's what is to click the diagonal
company working for
30 does mean really what ideal Society I
woke up after a discussion after
officials am I like person and when the
proper to my first half an hour and
those kind of gang dislike when the
swirl will allow you to throw with the
work now visually Morgan who unlike its
getting out of the epidemic at here like
they help you approach the rail warlock
where I want to be
I was living a secret self and then why
apparently known we have the privilege
of having a lot of people come to us at
CMU we have the optimal position but
it's different when we go to them and we
can come in sometimes the same badges on
and they're running some special session
to do it and I don't know it's like
these people great busy schedules you
know would be able to talk about hi uh
yeah I mean we haven't had any music
panelist yet which i think the program
can build on but uh that was cool
Richard oh yeah right i read your door
poster night is great Tarantino it even
though he doesn't remember talking to it
was cool to like have him in the
building and just like a couple of like
something we had a okay yeah like how
she went from him prob with like she's
latina she was like Tina Fey yeah in the
Chicago two seconds yeah but now she's
like working with nonprofits to like
optimize their content right and it just
got the wheels spinning play everything
like different backgrounds different
ideas different things of people are
damages Dave look just gave me more
ideas on like what I can do and how to
approach to
we are we saw her at the container that
night okay yeah we did yes and even in
the sessions to like premised wave was
like I know that really well and it said
oh I guess he was program i'm standing
here balance buying an acquisition
distribution and like all these things
and I'm like oh like I just show up on
set and I get like a subside and like a
call sheet and ice like make the day
though so it's cool to like have these
people come in and talk about what they
do so I can get a better understanding
of whether this place do because like
you can give me like you know a lie and
cheat like statement about what your job
entailed I don't clearly understand what
it is and so I'm actually possible to go
patient age and then that first my
interest and things that I wasn't really
that interested in
that's another great thing about this
program I don't think have to start
anyone knows what they want to damage
and it like I rely on a sizzling ah but
you just have well for film and TV
especially us and you have the
opportunity to see okay maybe I can go
this way maybe I can go that way like
this to women for sales and acquisitions
yeah but it's not an easy job but it's
basically traveling and seeing movies
all the time with what the film degree
an undergrad you like that's what I
wanted you to know i can pay me to watch
movies and go traveling but I was like
oh my gosh like I didn't even realize
you know and so I would love to do that
or i would also maybe once you get in
you know into writing or like so many
different things and and the other great
thing is that people always seem to jump
around like they work here for a little
bit and then right to try thinking out
and then maybe they go you know they
starting at Miami then they go in New
York or vice versa or I mean you worked
in Albuquerque right I was a clear
amount of it first exactly so like
there's so many different opportunities
different things to do to really so euro
your entertainment those sort of thing
which is awesome and I do stuff like I'm
a big picture person so even if I don't
want to go down that route it's
important for me to understand without
person which is coming club so that you
know in my own I can
help center facilitate their top just
one lunch like give me different avenues
I think one person is part of the
program who's going to be more in our
life next to John karna be Ava and gave
a panel about his experience and how
he's been fired thirty-nine percent of
the time yeah yeah but he's been aging
and all these other things right and
just to see how he continues to evolve
and continue to be successful in
business that might chew you up and spit
you out as high turnover just good to
hear it's like something real to like
fit me like yeah this is going to happen
problem
is inside our go help it easy
yeah so we'll wrap this up but just take
aways like your takeaways moving forward
you know what what from this week are
you going to pick with you as you start
your internships and move to LA and do
all of that oh we're lucky
man as I would have been like possible
higher
and and it keeps trying to talking and
be yourself and don't be afraid to ask
questions are talking
you never know Wow
I exactly the same thing and also
everyone to visit office because it's
under things absolutely amazing but yeah
like I said like I'm so glad that I
asked that question because i know i
would have Rupert and it's simple and
then afterwards I took a picture but
yeah and then again going off his life
so much more nonsense like everyone
fails like it's a part of a process you
know you just have to be resilient to
get right back up and it'll happen you
know being I mean this may be a little
naive but you sort of have a way of
working themselves out you know and you
ultimately will end up where you're
supposed to be you know even if you have
to wear ten different hats the force to
get there
you got a few months of being canceled
festivals and that was kind of a
you know how to I even you know to enjoy
the best
so I'm good to see waffles
gorgeous armor was it a little longer
iphone a better company office pool
houses planned everything had and
basically how to build networks even I'm
taking how will be better
I think well what you said just being
fortunate enough to be in this program
be presented with the opportunity to not
only go to New York for the first time
in my life but to come back to off in to
a festival where last year I was working
a bar on sixth Street pestering new
dishes design a guitar for radio station
like coming back to like enjoy it go to
these films talk to these people it was
also inspirational because he gave me a
few new ideas of what I want to do
entrepreneurial II maybe I spending some
time in LA we back to austin actually
doing something here
give me a few ideas any informations I
didn't have okay some well thank you
guys so much see ya